je sais que je vais pas mettre n'importe
quelle photo qui va me tomber sous la
main je vais je vais choisir enfin voilà
quoi et puis si je veux mettre une photo
de mon amie j'irai le lendemain à
l'école lui demander comme Amélie ces
CM2 sont les premiers détenteurs du
permis internet de la ville d'lancours
de classes ont répondu à l'appel de la
commune il était important à notre avis
de pouvoir faire une information aux
enfants sur les bonnes pratiques
d'internet je préfère dire les bonnes
pratiques d'Internet plutôt que les
dangers d'Internet les dangers c'est
oxiogène et du coup ils vont plus en'en
servir avec un guide fourni par le
ministère de l'Intérieur un agent
municipal a assuré quatre Séan de
formation conclu par un questionnaire
une manière de les sensibiliser aux
différents aspects
d'internet je pense que c'est important
de leur en parler souvent parce que ils
n'en ont pas forcément conscience ils
n'ont pas forcément conscience des
dégâts qu'ils peuvent faire sur leurs
camarades en est en mettant sur internet
des choses pas très sympathiques donc
c'est vraiment important qu'il soit
sensibiliser à tous ces thèmes et aussi
et surtout au thème du harcèlement sur
internet pour l'année scolaire 2016-27
la commune souhaite former de nouveaux
agents municipaux pour sensibiliser des
classes
supplémentaires